It was a moment of joy in Abidjan.
Supporters of former president Laurent Gbagbo
were watching the ICC decision:
Gbagbo supporters and members of his FPI party
feel as if they've been vindicated.
But the old divisions in the country haven't
healed yet:
His acquittal concerns the whole of the Ivory
Coast, because today we must look toward what
is ahead for the country, that's why we're
saying: "Ivory Coast first".
It was precisely this slogan 'Ivory Coast
first' that contributed to post-electoral
violence and bloodshed in 2010 and 2011.
The Gbagbo camp had alleged that the current
president, Alassane Ouattara, wasn't of Ivorian
descent.
The lawywers representing the current government
at the ICC are skeptical that the decision
to acquit Gbagbo will bring reconciliation
to the Ivory Coast.
3,500 deaths and no one is guilty?
That's going to be unbelievable for the Ivorian
people, and also for the international community.
The wife of Laurent Gbagbo, herself pardoned
by President Ouattara, says that the country
needs to forget for its own good.
Pardoning isn't a luxury -- pardoning is a
necessity for the Ivory Coast.
Everyone should understand -- whatever their
political party, ethnicity or religion they
need to understand and all the national and
international political players also should
understand this: if this country does not
succeed in pardoning past acts and is not
able to achieve reconciliation, this country
will explode.
This country will disappear.
It is everyone's duty and everyone's responsibility.
Speculation have already begun that Laurent
Gbagbo will run in the 2020 presidential election.